You may recall this explanation from our lesson on explanation-based learning.
There, the agent constructed an explanation like this to show that a specific
object was an example of a cup. For a good example of a pail, the agent may
have constructed similar explanation with the object being replaced by pail
everywhere. Now however, the agent knows that pail is not an example of a cup.
Something is not quite right with this explanation. We've also just seen how
the agent can identify the false suspicious relationship in this explanation.
It is identified, but the handle must be fixed because that is the feature that
separates the positive experiences from the negative experiences.
The question then becomes, how can this explanation be
repaired by incorporating handle as fixed? Where should handle as fixed go?